la nationale 174 se rallonge d'un
tronçon inauguré par un ministre dont
c'est le cv qui s'est rallongée depuis
la présidentielle
il a tracé sa route loin du territoire
auquel il doit toute sa légitimité
politique et l'ex député de cherbourg
devenu ministre des affaires européennes
a gagné un premier galon en faisant
avaler dans son propre camp la pilule
libéral du traité le budgétaire européen
à peine un mois plus tard c'est la
sortie de terrain et inattendu sur fond
de fraude fiscale de jérôme cahuzac qui
le propulse ministre du budget la route
de bernard cazeneuve passe maintenant
par bercy avec pour le petit soldat de
françois hollande
une seconde pilule à faire passer celle
de la rigueur si nous ne faisons pas cet
effort de maîtrise nous serons dans une
situation où pourront plus garantir le
fonctionnement des services publics
on sait que les français vont prendre
votre discours de vérité comme vous
l'appelez je ne sais pas si le
comprendront tout de suite mais je pense
que laisserait tallinn de laurent tenir
un autre lobbying mécanique et précis
pour convaincre à l'assemblée les
réunions à huis clos vont bon train je
vais rencontrer les parlementaires pour
parler du courage de droite financer en
sortant de ma région je répondrai à
vocation bernard casoni ne parle comme
un ministre du budget qui n'est pas
écologiste et je n'ai pas le sentiment
qu'il est et qu'il ait fait preuve d'une
particulière inclination pour la
fiscalité écologique sa première copie à
bercy sera forcément impopulaires
pourtant à quelques jours de la
présentation du budget bernard cazeneuve
et ici littéralement accueilli comme un
sauveur nous sommes à charbon son ancien
fief de député maire après quatre ans en
projet des constructions mécaniques de
normandie viennent de signer un contrat
de bateaux avec le mozambique pour 200
millions d'euros
aujourd'hui à cherbourg c'est la journée
de la gale voilà
le charbon était en difficulté j'étais
là toujours présent mais qui à la
couverture à soi quand tout va bien
c'est un genre de côté politique dans
lesquelles d'autres est excellent mais
moi j'avais moins de monde autre
ambiance à paris retour sur le front du
budget un projet de loi de finances qui
ne plaît pas au sénat deux fois le texte
a été rejeté
quand on a été élu pour redresser les
comptes d'un pays qui est en difficulté
dans quel énormément de tension de
division le rôle c'est d'apaiser de
réussir c'est ce que j'essaie de faire
en dernier ressort le marathon
budgétaire a pris fin avec le vote
définitif du parlement qui prévoit plus
de 370 milliards d'euros de dépenses et
15 milliards de prélèvements
supplémentaires
c'est bien un budget de rigueur qui a
été adopté
bernard cazeneuve son concepteur est
probablement la personne qui en sort le
plus un thème